we've already seen that if we were to
start with the differential equation the
derivative of y with respect to x is
equal to y and we had the initial
condition that y of 0 is equal to 1. the
particular solution to this given this
initial conditions is y of x is equal to
e to the x or i guess we could just say
y is equal to e to the x if we didn't
want to write it with the function
notation and that's all fair and well
and this works out well this is a
separable differential equation and we
can integrate things quite easily
but as you will see as you go further in
the world of differential equations most
differential equations are not so easy
to solve in fact many of them are
impossible to solve using analytic
methods and so given that what do you do
you've nicely described some phenomena
model some phenomena using differential
equations but if you can't solve it
analytically do you just give up
and the answer to that question is no
you do not just give up because we now
have computers and computers are really
good at numerical methods numerical
methods for approximating and giving us
a sense of what the solution to a
differential equation might look like
and so how do we do that well in this
video we can explore one of the most
straightforward numerical methods for
approximating a particular solution so
what we do is let me draw a little table
here
so a little table here
and so actually let me give myself some
i'm gonna do it over here on the left
hand side
so
a little table
x
and then y
with x y
and then d y
d x and you could set up a table like
this to to create a slope field you
could just pick all the you could sample
x's and y's in the cart in the in the x
y plane and then figure out for a first
order differential equation like this
what is the slope going to be at that
point you could construct a slow field
and we're going to do something kind of
related but instead of trying to
construct a slope field we're going to
start with this initial condition we
know that y of 0 is equal to 1. we know
that the particular solution of this
differential equation contains this
point so we're gonna start with that
point so we're gonna start with x is
equal to zero and let me do this in a
different color
we're gonna start with x is equal to
zero y is equal to one
which is that point right over there
and we're gonna say well okay what is
the what is the derivative at that point
well we know the derivative at any point
that or for any solution to this
differential equation the derivative is
going to be equal to the y value so in
this case the derivative is going to be
equal to y it's going to be equal to 1.
and in general if the derivative just
like what we saw in the case of slow
fields as long as the derivative is
expressed as a function of x's and y of
x's then you can figure out what the
what the slope of the tangent line will
be at that point and so you say okay
there's there's a slope of one at that
point
so i can
depict it like that
and instead of just keep doing that at a
bunch of points we'll say okay well
let's just
we know that the slope is changing or
it's probably changing for for most
cases let's just assume it's fixed until
our next x and then use that assumption
to estimate what the next y would be so
what am i talking about here
so when i talk about the next x we're
talking about well let's just step let's
say say for the sake of simplicity we're
going to have a delta x of 1
a change in x of 1. so we're going to
step from x equals 0 now we're going to
now step from that to
x is equal to 1. so we're now going to
go to actually let me not use that i use
that yellow color already for the actual
graph or for the actual e to the x so
now let's say x is equal to 1. so we've
our delta x
is one so we've just added one here
and what we can do in our in our little
approximation scheme here is let's just
assume that that slope was constant over
over that interval
so where does that get us to well if y
was at one and if i have a slope of one
for one more for one increase in x i'm
going to increase by y by one so then y
is going to increase by one and it's
going to get
to two and we see that point
right over there and you already might
see where this is going
now if this were actually a point on the
curve on the solution and if it was
satisfying this what would then the
derivative be well the derivative is
equal to y the slope of the tangent line
is going to be equal to y so in this
case
the slope of the tangent line is now
going to be equal to two and we could
depict that let me depict that in
magenta here so
it is going to be
2. so it's going to look
the slope of the tangent line there is
going to be 2.
and so what does that tell us well if we
step
if we step by our delta x one more
so when our x is equal to two
what should the corresponding
what should the corresponding y be
well let's see
now for every one that we increase in
the x in the x direction we should
increase 2 in the y direction because
the slope is 2.
so the very next one should be
4 y is equal to 4. so
we could imagine we have now kind of had
a constant slope and we get to that
point right over there
and now we can do the same thing well if
we assume dydx based on the differential
equation has to be equal to y we say
okay the slope of the tangent line there
is going to be the same thing as y it's
going to be
and so if we step our x up
by 1
if we increment our x by 1 again once
again we just decided to increment by 1.
we could have incremented by 10 we could
have incremented by 0.01 and you could
guess which one is going to give you a
more accurate result but if we step up
by 1 now and our slope is 4 well we're
going to increase by if we increase x by
1 we're going to increase y by 4. so we
are going to get
we are going to get to
and so we are at the point 3 comma 8
which is right
over here and so for this next stretch
the next stretch
is going
is going to look like that and as you
can see just by doing this we have been
able to
approximate what the particular solution
looks like and you might say hey sal
well you know that's not so good of an
approximation and my reply to you is
well yeah i mean depends on what your
goals are but i did this by hand i
didn't even do this using a computer and
i and because i wanted to do it by hand
i took fairly large delta x steps
if i wanted a better approximation i
could have lowered the delta x and let's
do that so let's take another scenario
so let's do another scenario where
instead of delta x equal one let's say
delta x equals one half
so once again x
y
and
the derivative of y with respect to x
so now let's say i want to take so we
know this first point given it we're
given this initial condition when x is
zero
y is one and so the slope of the tangent
line is going to be one
but then if we're incrementing by
one-half so then when x is i'll just
write it as 0.5
0.5
what is our new what is our new y going
to be well we're going to assume that
our slope from this to this is this
slope right over here so our slope is 1.
so if we increase x by 0.5 we're going
to increase y by 0.5 and we're going to
get to
1.5 so
we're going to when we get 0.5 1.5 we
get to that point right over there
actually you're having trouble seeing
that
this stuff right over here is this point
right over here and now our new slope is
going to be 1.5
which is going to look which is going to
look
like
which is going to look like
actually not quite that steep
i don't want to overstate how good an
approximation is and it's starting to
get a little bit messy but it's going to
look something like that and what you
would see if you kept doing this process
so if your slope is now 1.5 when you
increment x by another 0.5 or you get to
1.
so now if you increment by
if you increment by 0.5 and your slope
is 1.5 your y is going to increase
increment by half of that by .75 and so
you're going to get to 2.25
so now you get to 1
2.25 which is this point right over here
and once again this is a better
approximation remember in the original
one y of 1 you know should be equal to e
y of 1 and the actual solution should be
equal to e 2.7 on and on and on and on
and on now in this one y of y of y of 1
got us to 2. and this one y of 1 got us
to 2.25 once again closer to the actual
reality closer to e instead of stepping
by 0.5 if we stepped by 0.1 we would get
even closer if we stepped by
if we stepped by
zero .0001 we would get even closer and
closer and closer so there's a bunch of
interesting things here this is actually
how most differential equations or or
techniques that are derived from this or
that are based on numerical methods
similar to this
are how most differential equations get
solved you know it's not the exact same
solution or the same method that the
idea that most differential equations
are actually solved or i guess you could
say simulated with a numerical method
because most of them actually cannot be
solved in analytical form now you might
be saying hey well what method is this
one right over here called well this
right over here is called euler's
euler's
method
after the famous leonard euler
euler's
euler's method and not only actually is
this one a good way of approximating
what the solution to this or any
differential equation is but actually
for this differential equation in
particular you can actually even use
this to find
to find e with more and more and more
precision anyway hopefully you found
that exciting